good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight oh the drama
but at least the chauvin trial is over
officer derek chauvin was convicted
yesterday on
all counts the trial went on for more
than a month and at times the testimony
was complex and it was technical
but at the center of the case there was
always really just one piece of relative
relevant evidence and it was the
videotape of george floyd's death in the
street in minneapolis in may
if you haven't seen the tape recently it
remains every bit as shocking as the day
it was shot
you watch it and you can see that george
floyd knows on some level
that he's going to die and in the end of
course he does die
it's crushing that way millions of
americans reacted in that way they
sought they were horrified
and many decided as they watched it that
officer chauvin must have committed
an act of criminal brutality so really
it's not surprising that the jury
yesterday concluded the same thing
the images in that tape seem to tell the
whole story
and in fact honestly it is possible that
even if no one
outside the courtroom in minneapolis had
ever seen that tape just the jury
it's possible derek chovan still would
have been convicted the tape is that
powerful
that's totally possible unfortunately we
don't know that we can only speculate
about it because that's not at all what
actually happened
the george floyd video went around the
world it became the centerpiece of a new
political movement
political actors harnessed the emotion
over that video
and over floyd's death to control the
country and change it forever
and then and this is the key and the
thing that we should think a lot about
in the last month some of these same
people went further than that
they worked to change the outcome of
derek chovan's trial
and that is the one thing that we can
never allow no matter how we feel about
a specific case
civilized countries have impartial
systems of justice that's the hallmark
of a civilized country
what separates the country you want to
live in from a place you don't even want
to visit
civilized countries demand above all
that every citizen is held to precisely
the same standard under the law as every
other citizen is and that applies
no matter how popular or unpopular a
particular defendant might be
it applies no matter the alleged crime
countries like this civilized countries
do not tolerate jury
intimidation you see it you stop it they
don't allow the threat of violence to
influence the outcome of a trial
ever under any circumstances that would
be the opposite of justice it would be
mob rule
and america used to strive hard to be
like that
and yet just yesterday we saw the
president of the united states
throw his backing behind derrick
chauvin's prosecution and he did that
even as the jury in minneapolis was
still deliberating the case
we saw one of the most powerful members
of the united states congress tell a
group of angry people
they should act out in violence if the
jury dared to acquit
we watched the city of minneapolis
concede responsibility for the death of
george floyd
right in the middle of the trial before
derek chovan's lawyer could even sum up
his case
and then least noted but most ominously
of all
we saw thugs threaten a defense witness
with death they smeared pig blood on the
door of what they thought was his house
and then get away with it no one in
authority seemed especially interested
in catching them
these were terrifying acts it doesn't
matter whether you think that derek
chovan was guilty and deserves what he
got
doesn't matter who you voted for it
doesn't matter what you think about
anything else
seeing mobs trying to influence this
trial
should shock and horrify you at least as
much as the george floyd video did
this is a picture of a country moving
backward at high speed
but the strange thing is that most
people didn't seem
shocked or upset by any of this they
seem relieved by the verdict
they'd of course seen the boarded up
buildings they'd watched the troops in
the streets and they
understood very well what an acquittal
would mean
they believed that a conviction whether
it was justified or not
would buy the country peace many people
thought
this not just cynical people most people
including many republicans some of them
said so
if we obeyed maxine waters and ignored
the pig blood
hopefully the chaos would end and you
can see where they felt that way
after 11 months of violence and
intimidation from blm mostly
unrestrained
americans just decided to pay the ransom
they understood derek chauvin as a
sacrifice for the sins of a nation
and on television they told us this was
the case they said it in the clearest
terms
america is on trial they told us it's
not just derek chovan one cop from
minneapolis on the stand no
it's all of us on the stand our history
our culture
our system and we internalized that and
we went along with it
but we were foolish to go along with it
a wise country stands
on its principles it puts down mobs it
does not obey mobs
mobs are never sated it doesn't matter
what
demands you follow they demand more
and now they are demanding more not
surprisingly here are the two most
powerful people in the united states
reacting to yesterday's verdict and keep
in mind as you watch this
that no one has ever shown that race or
skin color played any role in the death
of george floyd
if you watch the trial you know that but
these people didn't watch the draw
they're not interested in the trial
the details of the case their plan is to
use the trial
the way they use george floyd
a measure of justice isn't the same
as equal justice this verdict
brings us a step closer and
the fact is we still have work to do
we still must reform the system
no one should be above the law and
today's verdict sends that message
but it's not enough we can't stop here
but it's not enough we can't stop here
we must reform
the system they don't say how but their
intent
is obvious they mean it so it turns out
that derek chovan's conviction was not
the
end of the revolution it was the not the
terminus of
what we've seen for the past year after
the death of george floyd it was just
the beginning
of the revolution the attorney general
himself announced yesterday that the
investigation into floyd's death
overseen presumably by avowed racist
kristin clark of the civil rights
division
is quote ongoing it's ongoing
didn't we just have a month-long trial
that presented all the evidence yes we
did
but once again that was just the start
so what can we expect next it's hard to
know exactly but there are signs
here for example our blm activist
celebrating the verdict last night in
new york
now george floyd died 1200 miles
from new york in a totally different
region presumably they didn't know
george floyd
they probably didn't watch his trial but
for people like this
justice for george floyd isn't the point
never ending ethnic conflict is the
point listen
we don't want you here we don't want you
we don't want you here
we don't want you we don't want your
money
we don't want your [ __ ] sacrifice
so people with the wrong skin color now
have to leave new york city they're not
allowed to own restaurants
that's what they just said everyone of
course pretends not to notice that they
said it but they did say it
the point is people didn't used to talk
like this in public
and when they did they were scolded at
the very least you can't have a
multi-ethnic nation hold together if
people are going to scream stuff like
that on the street without anyone
disagreeing with them
so why are they doing it now well
they're doing it for one simple reason
it gets results
radicalism works violence works that's
the lesson
we've taught them being the mob
that lesson and here's at least one blm
activist who's willing to say it out
loud
it was a mixture of violent and
non-violent protests
that yielded this result that's the
bottom line
america doesn't listen to us when we
march
peacefully i'm not saying people will be
back in the street
but america must know that if you
continue to allow us to be
murdered in the streets without justice
we will raise
hell in america so it's that simple
violence gets results now that's a
threat
of course but it's also unfortunately
true writing does work
when you burn cities you get what you
want you get rich from corporate
handouts you can buy four homes
you get the jury verdicts you have
demanded rioters know this very well
even if the rest of us will not admit it
by allowing wendy's to be torched and
macy's to be looted and police stations
to be destroyed the rest of us have
relinquished our power as citizens
and instead handed it to the most
violent unreasonable and least
productive people in the country
why would we do something like this
maybe historians will be able to explain
it
in the meantime prepare for the next
phase but once again don't kid yourself
derek chovan's conviction did not settle
accounts
it merely increased the debt here's the
democratic party's pet academic radical
henry rogers now known as
ibram x kendi letting us know that derek
chauvin was just the beginning
national transformation is on the way
so now what chauvin is headed to jail
but is america headed to justice is
justice convicting a police officer
or is justice convicting america it is
easy to just blame
individual officers like derek shovin
but the problem is structural
the problem is historic justice has
convicted america
now we must put in the time transforming
this nation so we've all been
convicted of murder and by the way you
can't blame ibrahim
x kendi that guy's gotten many millions
of dollars from our captains of industry
he's
incubated within the academy you may be
paying tuition to support his salary
why are you doing that why are the rest
of us doing it as he calls for punishing
you for a murder you didn't commit
so this transformation the ibrahim x
kendi is calling for what exactly is
that going to look like what's the shape
of the reform to come
well bree newsome has some ideas newsom
is one of the most famous blm activists
in the country
this morning she announced that
henceforth police officers should not be
allowed to break up
knife fights quote teenagers have been
having fights including fights involving
knives for eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of the
teenagers
everyone should be frightened that the
ruling white elite have done such a
thoroughly successful job of not only
disconnecting us from the means of basic
self-sufficiency
but also convincing us we need armed
white officers to manage our children
and communities end quote you may
roll your eyes at ibrahim ex kendi or
the president and vice president or
brie newsome and the many like her but
be assured
that the biden administration does not
roll its eyes it takes every word very
seriously and that means your
neighborhood
may soon see reforms like this one and
what will happen then
well if you live in an affluent
neighborhood you'll be absolutely fine
because you'll hire private security
and there'll be many american police
officers who are eager to become private
security guards because it pays better
and you don't have to listen to ibrahim
x kennedy he'll doubtless have them
but for everyone else what next well
here's some data and it comes from of
all places the website vox which
cites the following study quote from
2014 to 2019 a researcher called
campbell
tracked more than 1600 blm protests
across the country largely in bigger
cities
with nearly 350 000 protesters now the
net result was quote
roughly 300 fewer police homicides in
census places that saw blm protests
okay 300. but here's the cost of that
and we're quoting
campbell's research also indicates that
these protests correlate with a 10
increase in murders in the areas that
saw blm protests
that means from 2014 to 2019
they were somewhere between 1 000 and 6
000 more homicides
that would have been expected if places
with protests were on the same trend as
places that did not have protests
you following the math there thanks to
blm
says this researcher police shot about
300
fewer suspects and in exchange for that
up to 6 000 new murders took place many
of innocents
and children so that's the bargain that
we have made
and we just doubled down on